ساذهب الان الى ضيفنا يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك
سيد يوسف هذه الهدنه الى اي مدى انتم
ملتزمون بها انتم رحبتم بها ولكن هل سنشهد
التزام من قبلكم
تفاصيل يعني ما هو دور الولايات المتحده
كان في هذه الهدنه لانه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي هو من اعلن عن هذه الهدنه نعم
نعم نحن تلقينا اتصال من الخارجيه
الامريكيه
واقترحوا هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام نحن وافقنا
عليها واصدرنا بيان بذلك هذه الهدنه
الزانيه قد قد تتطور الى هدنه دائمه وهذا
ما نعمل فيه لان نحن لم نبدا الحرب ولم
نكن دعاه حرب ولا نريد استمرار الحرب فهذه
الحرب بالتدريتها قوه معروفه واعلنت عنها
وهاجرت هذه الحرب كلفت المواطنين كل
فعاليه ثمنها كبير جدا نزح الناس الى
الولايات هربا من الرصاص هربا من القصف
الجوي لم يشهد الخرطوم معارك من قبل بهذه
الضراوه
نفهم من حديثك بان هذه الهدنه من الممكن
ان تكون مؤشر لوقف اطلاق نار كامل
لنهايه هذا الصراع لنهايه هذا الاشتباك
هذا ممكن اذا التزم الطرف الاخر بالهدنه
اذا التزم بوقف الحرب هذه الحرب نحن لم
ننتظرها ولم نكن دعاه هذا ولم نرتب لها
فوجئنا بها كما فوجئ بها كل الشعب
السوداني ولذلك نحن التزمنا كل الهدنه
الانسانيه
السابقه والتزمنا بهذه الهدنه واعلنا ذلك
وسائل الاعلام وتظل قواتنا ملتزمه لن
تتحرك بموقع الى موقع كان اختراق الهدنه
دائما يتم عن طريق الطيران وبمشاهده كل
العالم
يتهمكم بانكم انتم من تخرقون هذه الهدنه
هذه دعايه هذه دعايه الجيش الاسلامي الجيش
الاسلامي السوداني يتهمنا باي شيء هذه
العصابه التي تدير الجيش مستعده لفعل اي
شيء لاتهامنا به في حاله حرب اعلاميه هذه
المجموعه فشلت الان على ارض الواقع نحن
نطمن شعبنا ان الجيش الان في المناطق التي
نسيطر عليها ليس لديه مشاه كل الذي
يستخدمه هو الطيران والغذف المدفعي من
بعيد نحن في المناطق التي نسيطر عليها
سنسهل حياه المدنيين ما هي هذه المناطق
التي تسيطرون عليها استاذ يوسف نحن نسيطر
على بحر بشكل شبه كامل مسيطر على الخرطوم
والمواقع الحيويه في الخرطوم حتى جنوب
الخرطوم الى الى حدود جبل اولياء نقفل على
طريق مدني مسافه 20 كيلو خارج الخرطوم
مسيطره على شرق النيل بشكل كامل نسيطر على
مواقع كبيره في ام درمان حتى كرري حتى
قاعده وادي سيدنا نحن تقريبا نسيطر على
مناطق واسعه
شهادات من ناس كانوا بالخرطوم وخرجوا بان
هناك عمليات نهب وسلب ما دمتم انتم
تسيطرون على هذه المناطق لماذا انتم غير
قادرين على فرض الامن فيها ووقف هذه
العمليات التي تسبب الماساه للناس لانهم
يسرقون مصانع يسرقون مخازن محال تجاريه
نعم نحن دعني اقول لك نحن في حاله حرب
ومواجهات وقصف جوي نسيطر على مناطق لكن لا
نستطيع ان نسيطر على كل بقاله نخيطر حدث
لها في منطقه نحن نسيطر عليها بسيجا وهذه
هذا النهب نشك انه ان الجهه التي دبرت
عمليه نهب مصانع سيغا او المخازن هي
مجموعه منظمه مجموعه دخلت بسيارات
[موسيقى]
مرتبه اخلت المواقع بشكل مرتب وعبرت
بشوارع نحن لا نسيطر عليها هذه هذا النهب
سببه ايضا هنالك اغلاق كامل للبقالات
ويخرج حتى المواطنون
ليس الجيش السوداني من يتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع ولكن الناس في السودان يعني اذا
كنت تتابع مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الكثير
من المواطنين السودانيين يتهمونكم بانكم
انتم من تدخلون على البيوت وتجبروهم على
الطبخ مثلا للقوات
على الارض
والكثير من التجاوزات كيف ترد عليهم نحن
لم نجبر اي مواطن ولم ندخل بقوات الدعم
السريع لم تدخل البيت اي مواطن هذه
الاشياء نسمع بها في مناطق مثلا الصبادي
سمعنا الصبابي نحن نحافظها من الخارج ولم
ندخل شوارعها اصلا هذه دعايه هي دعايه حرب
فنحن نواجه الكثير من الاشياء الكثير من
الاشياء ونتعامل معها مثل ارتداء بعض
الناس زي الدعم السريع والاستحام السفارات
مثل استخدام سيارات عليها لوحات الدعم
السريع لتهديد مواطنين وسلبهم لاخراج ذلك
في الميديا هذه كلها عمليات حرب لا تقود
جهات استخباريه
يقال بان هذا القصف اليوم طالما مخازن
للدعم السريع فيه اسلحه
هذا هذه دعايه رخيصه يعلم مواطنها
الكلاكله ان ليس للدعم السريع وجود في
الكلاكله ولابسه سياره واحده وليس لدينا
مخازن وليس لدينا سكن لضباطنا هناك ليس
لدينا اي وجود في الكلاكله جميع مواطنين
لا يعلمون ذلك
ايضا ليست منطقه مواجهات لم تتعرض
لمواجهات طيله الفتره الماضيه الكلاكله
لمنطقه المدنيه ليس لدينا جهه سكنات
عسكريه او مخازن هذه الاكاذيب التي يصبرها
الناس يمكن الاتصال بالمواطنين الكلاكله
لمعرفه حقيقتها ليس لدينا اي وجود في
منطقه الكلاكله ومنطقه الكلاك بعيده عن
المواجهات العشر ايام الماضيه لم تحدث
فيها ولا معرفه ليس لدينا فيها اي مخزن
ولا اي وجود للدعم السريع ولا اي ارتكاز
قدام السريع في هذه المنطقه هذه عمليه
غادره استهدفت مواطنين عزا بالطيران وليست
وليس في في في في في في لوحدها هنالك
عمليات لم لم تخرج للطيران لم تخرج
للاعلام هنالك قتل المواطنين في شنبات
هنالك استهداف لمسجد جنبات في يوم صلاه
العيد نحن رفعنا صوره في في في في
السوشيال ميديا هنالك تدمير واسع لمنازل
في في قبل ان انهي معك اريد ان اعود الى
موضوع الهدنه ما هي الضمانات التي قدمت
لكم حتى قلت بانه من الممكن ان تتطور هذه
الهدنه لتكون دائما
انا اتحدث عن رغبتنا الرغبتنا التي
تاكدناها مرارا ضد الحرب ويجبرنا على
الحرب للدخول فيها لا توجد ضمانات الان
ولكن يوجد مقترح بهدنه انسانيه لمده ثلاثه
ايام اذا التزم بها الطرف الثاني ما دواعي
الحرب اصلا دواعي الحرب يعرفها الطرف الذي
تذكرها وبالتالي اذا لديه اهداف يمكن
تحقيقها لتح
ددها وهذه اهداف بعيده ان الانقلاب الذي
يدبر اللون الاسلاميون فشل يعني الشروط
لديكم لايقاف الحرب لانه السيد حمدتي كان
يعني كان صعد كثيرا بموضوع الجيش السوداني
والسيد البرهان الان هل من الممكن ان
توقفوا هذه الحرب من دون اي شروط
هذه الحرب لن تتوقف اكيد بالتاكيد من دون
اي شروط ولكن هذه الشروط طفرت في طاوله
مخفيه اطلاق النار اذا كان هنالك
وقت في اطلاق النار دائم هذه الشروط ستوضع
في الطاوله وفي تلك اللحظه يمكن ان نضع
شروطنا لاننا الان
وليس لصالح ق سريع او لصالح الدعم السريع
يعني التزم الجيش بهذه الايام الثلاثه ولم
يتم اي خرق يمكن ان نعتبر بانكم مستعدون
للذهاب الى المفاوضات يعني هذه الهدنه
ستكون هي الحد الفاصل للعوده الى الى
الجلوس الى الجلوس على الطاوله
فوضات اخته اطلاق النار نحن الان كما
اسلفت لك اننا لا لا لا نريد شعبنا ان
يعاني من هذه الحرب ولكن الطرف الذي
ابتدرها لديه اهداف لم تتحقق ولن يستطيع
تحقيقها ولذلك ما دواعي الحرب لقد فشلت
فشلت خطتهم فشل كل شيء وعليهم الان
والخضوع للمحاسبه والخضوع
لجنه دائما لوقت المراقبه اطلاق النار هذه
عمليه يمكن ان تتم لكن نحن الان نريد نجاح
الهدنه الانسانيه لان
شعبه شكرا لك من الخرطوم يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات